Hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
Centroamérica desde Costa Rica hoy
hablaremos sobre los flujos migratorios
que impactan esta nación que a lo largo
de su historia ha abierto sus puertas a
migrantes de distintas nacionalidades
Costa Rica es uno de los países
latinoamericanos con un mayor porcentaje
de población extranjera la que puede
llegar a sobrepasar el 15%, Pero además
se ha convertido en parte de la ruta que
se trazan decenas de miles de migrantes
que transitan del Sur del continente
rumbo a Estados Unidos Les contaremos
sobre la saturación del sistema de
Refugio costarricense que acumula unas
200.000 solicitudes mayoritariamente de
nicaragüenses y sobre los migrantes en
tránsito principalmente venezolanos que
realizan una parada en este país antes
de continuar su travesía hacia el norte
América Latina es un corredor de
migrantes por el que transitan quienes
buscan llegar a Estados Unidos del sur
de América del Caribe e inclusive
procedentes de Asia y África los
migrantes emprenden un viaje peligroso
que implica el paso por el Darién una
espesa e inhóspita selva en la que
delincuentes acechan a los migrantes
a pesar de ello el flujo migratorio
crece en grandes proporciones solo en
agosto pasado 32 mil migrantes cruzaron
el Darién de los cuales 23.000 eran de
Venezuela una vez logran salir de la
selva llegan hasta la frontera entre
Panamá y Costa Rica donde reciben
asistencia humanitaria en semanas
recientes ha aumentado la cantidad de
familias con niños pequeños
ha aumentado en un más de un 50 por
ciento en los últimas prácticamente
semanas y cada vez más nos encontramos
las personas con problemas
físicos pero también inclusive con
problemas emocionales
ese aumento es visible en ciudades
costarricenses como la capital San José
donde deambulan decenas de venezolanos
en el centro vendiendo en las calles o
pidiendo ayuda es una situación inédita
pues usualmente los migrantes en
tránsito han pasado inadvertidos
tratando de llegar lo más rápido posible
y sin dejar verse Hasta la frontera
norte con Nicaragua
yusmely salió junto a su familia por la
crisis económica en Venezuela y debido a
la situación de salud de su hijo que
solo tiene un riñón
llegamos acá y ya no no contábamos con
con lo económico pues con la con el
dinero para seguir y nos tocó parar acá
porque tampoco traíamos para la comida
Yo estoy aquí todos los días Entonces si
consigo un trabajo puede que me quede
puede ser por lo menos un mes para
reunir más dinero para poder seguir
Carlos lleva dos meses durmiendo en las
calles en distintos países varios de sus
compatriotas también descansan a la
intemperie algunos tienen un poco más de
suerte y encuentran lugar en los
albergues como este atendido por la
asociación obras del Espíritu Santo acá
me he planteado en varias oportunidades
la posibilidad de quedarme por Buscar
una estabilidad para mis hijas pues a
veces más que toda la niña más grande me
dice Mami ya no quiero ya no quiero
seguir viajando Ya estoy cansada de eso
ya yo me quiero quedar pero sí sigue
siendo la misma sigue siendo la misma
meta desde un principio esa meta es
Estados Unidos el destino que consideran
les dará una mejor vida no solo los
venezolanos han salido de su país a
causa de la crisis política y económica
en el vecino Nicaragua donde manda un
gobierno Aliado del venezolano se vive
un Éxodo sin precedentes con unos
500.000 nicaragüenses que han salido en
los últimos cuatro años según
especialistas en temas migratorios una
dirigido hacia Estados Unidos mientras
otra llega a Costa Rica
decenas de miles de nicaragüenses han
arribado a este país a lo largo de
décadas por razones económicas huyendo
de conflictos políticos y de desastres
por fenómenos naturales pero desde 2018
se incrementó considerablemente el flujo
debido a la crisis sociopolítica en
Nicaragua son 200.000 solicitudes de
refugio acumuladas en ese tiempo más del
90% son de nicaragüenses que huyen de la
persecución política y del hambre el
sistema de Refugio se ha saturado por lo
que estas personas deben esperar años
para obtener una respuesta y mientras
tanto viven con un carnet provisional
que aunque tiene validez es
menospreciado por algunos patronos
entidades bancarias o en los puestos de
salud
si te facilita muchas cosas pero te
dificulta en esencia poder acceder en
igualdad de condiciones a diferentes
derechos y eso evidentemente precariza
la vida y te dejan una condición de
vulnerabilidad legal es el caso de elea
Valle del interior de Nicaragua que
denunció que sus hijos y esposo fueron
asesinados por el ejército nicaragüense
llegó el año pasado a solicitar asilo y
su cita de elegibilidad fue agendada
para 2028 le preocupa que le han negado
el acceso a salud en varias ocasiones
tengo un niño especial verdad y no lo
atendieron a ninguno de ellos ni a mí y
tal vez que este momento no me Han
atendido las autoridades aseguran que
mantendrán su política de brazos
abiertos para la población migrante pero
piden donaciones a la comunidad
internacional para atender estos flujos
migratorios en el caso de la migración
en tránsito las autoridades estiman que
unas mil personas se encuentran por día
a territorio costarricense y señalan que
la adecuada atención de estos flujos
debe ser compartida el tema no es de
Costa Rica es un tema regional es un
tema continental y esto cualquier
decisión que tome cualquiera de los
países que se encuentran en la ruta o en
el recorrido que hacen estas personas
migrantes puede impactar negativamente
en las situaciones de otros países hasta
aquí con este enlace Centroamérica sobre
Costa Rica Gracias por habernos
acompañado para ver nuestros programas
síganos por France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]